[Music]
so what do you remember about your
parents death
car crashing house 14 you started having
discipline problems kicked out of three
boarding schools after that let's talk
about that day on the beach
Katrina I love you so much
what happened you gave up everything
after that didn't you Mitch no not
everything how'd you think you're gonna
kill Mansoor wipe out his whole cell for
starters yeah I like your agenda I know
exactly what to do with you
[Music]
so what do I need to know about this guy
he's a warrior best I've ever known so
bad things happen dude anyone kill those
me or terrorists you think that
qualifies you for my selection process
my guess is if you and I go hand to hand
you can probably figure out inside 20
seconds with an I have what it takes to
make it through selection process so you
say kill me you think it's like cement
stroke right here like this well in the
movies what is it you think we do here
so people need to be killed how dare
you're a ghost you don't exist
[Music]
he's ready Stan he's not ready
[Music]